I found I could have drop below a
certain threshold of sleep and although
I'd be awake for hours and I could
sustain it I would get less done try
living the Elon Musk lifestyle for a
week try sleeping six six thousand hours
try to work like he's working it's great
to try different clothes on just to see
how they fit important for us to
remember the joy in what we do it's
important to be effective in our
workplace but it's important to
cultivate the moments that just bring us
joy rise and shine it's expresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
on to the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message find balance over
to you Elon Musk your CEO of two
companies you're chairman of Solar City
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this well you get any sleep
oh yes sometimes not enough so you cook
is really great because because if you
find if I don't get enough sleep then
I'm I'm quite grumpy I mean obviously I
think most people that way and and and
also I can try to sort of figure out
what's the right amount of sleep because
I thought I could have dropped below a
certain threshold of sleep and although
I'd be awake for hours and I could
sustain it I would get less done because
mental acuity would be affected so I
found generally the right number for me
is around six to six and a half hours on
average per night that's not too bad
yeah and any other tips on average that
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously I mean do
you do you find I mean I know you're up
here on Monday Tuesday is it all Tesla
when you're up in Silicon Valley and all
SpaceX Wednesday Thursday having a
smartphone is incredibly helpful because
that means you can do email during
interstitial periods like you're in a
car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere you can do email
practically when you're awake and and so
that's really helpful to have email for
SpaceX and Tesla integrated on my phone
and then it's just you have to apply a
lot of hours to actual working actually
working so the way I generally do it as
I'll be working at SpaceX on Monday and
then Monday night fly to the area spent
Tuesday and Wednesday at the Baria then
let a Tesla and then fly back on
Wednesday night spend Thursday and
Friday at SpaceX in in the last several
months then I would fly back here on a
Saturday and either spend Saturday and
Sunday at Tesla or spend Saturday at
Tesla and Sunday at SpaceX and where did
the boys fit in you have five sons yeah
what did we tag along with dad on some
of these bits I do drag them along and a
lot of things actually they're
remarkably unimpressed by finding
balance is an exercise in self-awareness
and I think it's one of the most
important exercises you can go through
because yes it's great to understand how
Elon Musk has his schedule or Will Smith
or whoever it is that you look up to and
it's great even to try it for a week try
living the Elon Musk lifestyle for a
week try what sleep in six six thousand
hours try to work like he's working it's
great to try different clothes on just
to see how they fit what ends up
happening is you judge yourself based up
your definition of balance in your
schedule against somebody else you feel
like because you're not working like
Elon Musk is you're not gonna have
success and that's gonna be the ultimate
failure because if you are constantly
judging your definition of balance basis
of what other people are doing around
you it's a it's a guaranteed loss you
need to understand what balance looks
like for you how much time you're gonna
spend on your business how much time
you're gonna spend sleeping how much
time you gonna spend with your wife with
your kids with your husband with your
family all of those things for each
individual it looks a little different
my favorite story on this is still
Dwayne Johnson where he wakes up four or
five hours early before going to movie
set because he needs to work out
because if he does not work out every
morning he feels totally out of balance
now to me that sounds crazy I would
rather sleep right if he's averaging
five hours of sleep on a movie set I'd
rather sleep two-three hours more and
work out a little bit less but for him
that's what balance looks like and if I
judge myself worth and my schedule based
off of what dwayne johnson schedule is
I'm always gonna lose because he's doing
him and he doesn't care what everybody
else is doing and I'm too busy trying to
be him instead of being me and that's
how most people think that's the buckets
that most people fall into and so if you
learn how Dwayne does it or you learn
how Ilan does it or anybody else it's
great to try on the clothes it's great
just to see how it feels maybe they're
doing something different that can help
you figure out balance better for
yourself but if it doesn't work out
they'll judge yourself it's just like
watching these top ten rule videos that
I put out not every rule is gonna
resonate with you take the one or two
that really fit and run with them if you
try on Dwayne's schedule you try and
Ilan schedule it may be a total misfit
that's fine
but there may be one thing that they do
that really works for you great keep
that and ditch the rest and stop judging
yourself the other quick thing I want to
talk about here is sleep so many people
focus on how much sleep you're getting
where what I would encourage you to do
is think about what are you doing while
you're awake right if ilana sleeping six
or six and a half hours I guarantee you
if he slept eight hours or nine hours or
12 hours if he's sleeping 12 hours the
12 hours that he's awake he's getting
more stuff done in the 16 hours that
you're awake and so much more important
than looking at how much sleep you're
getting and how much sleep these these
higher performers are getting audit your
schedule audit your day-to-day audit the
hours that you are actually awake and
see how productive they actually are I
was doing a photo shoot recently taking
some pictures new headshots and social
media shots and while my photographer
was setting up the next scene I was I
was working while he's doing his thing
instead of just waiting I'm working I'm
on Instagram making video responses I'm
on email responding like every minute
counts I try to make every minute count
it's important to me
ingvar comp rad who started IKEA said
divide your life up into ten minute
chunks and then waste as few of those 10
minute chunks
as possible and that applies not just a
business that applies to life like when
I'm with my wife I'm with my wife we're
together we're enjoying that moment
together whether that's for an hour a
day five hours a day an entire day on a
weekend like I'm with her and I want
that time to mean something same thing
with my son same thing with my dog same
thing with my team same thing with my
business it's not about for me balancing
how much time I'm spending in my
business versus with my wife or
something else it's much more the time
I'm spending in all these places has to
count where I bet you if I jumped into
your schedule your day to day you're
wasting a ton of time during the day and
you think the answer is to wake up an
hour earlier where it's not the answer
is make every minute count that you are
currently awake try that first before
you give up on sleep and so I think
ultimately it's great to learn from
successful people that's what my entire
channel is about I love it I love violin
success I think that's how you become
the best version of yourself but you
can't judge yourself against what
somebody else is doing because
ultimately your goal is not to be them
your goal is to be a better version of
you and so to make that happen you're
taking different little tiny pieces from
different people to see what fits well
with you and that means most of the
things that you learn from them will not
work 99% of the things that you learn
from somebody may not work but if that
1% works and help you grow helps you get
stronger helps you get better then
that's your ultimate goal and please
please please stop judging yourself
based off of somebody else's definition
of balance and somebody else's number of
hours that they're working is somebody
else's number of hours that they are
sleeping at the end of the day you don't
want their life you don't want to be a
junior version of them you want to be
the best version of you and so figuring
out balance is an important exercise and
self-awareness and they'll hope you get
it down because when you do it makes all
the difference in the world now I've got
a really special bonus clip but before
that question of the day I want to know
from you what is one thing that you have
learned from someone who's had a lot of
success with this elan or somebody else
that you've adopted and it's stuck one
kind of habit one scheduled hack
something that you've learned about your
routine that you've learned from
somebody else and you apply on a daily
basis and it's actually had a big
difference for you leaving the comments
below I'm really cured
to find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
I got great advice from you know one of
the people that totally fascinates me is
Bob Iger he's the CEO of the Walt Disney
ABC world and he so his job is so weird
to me because he is in charge of
everything from like a Disney cruise to
George Stephanopoulos ABC News like he
thought he had to like a theme park to
scandal like every all of that falls
into the ABC Disney family and I asked
him and it was very helpful to me I
asked him a few months ago like how do
you decide what you're gonna work on in
a day and he said something so valuable
to me so I'm gonna share with you guys
he said 80% of his time he tries to
think about where can I have impact
where am I going to make a difference in
the day today so it may not usually be
Disney cruises but sometimes it needs to
be because the cruise business has been
doing what the cruise business is doing
or that's not quoting him by the way but
there you know it may sometimes it's a
Broadway show that's about to open
sometimes it's they eat the ESPYs cuz
ESPN that's where his focus needs to be
so it's really about like where can I
have impact today and the other where am
I needed the other 20% is what brings me
joy you know so there are certain movie
projects that fall under the ABC disney
world that bring him joy or certain
shows or certain you know an opening of
a park or there are certain things that
bring him that just fill him up that
fall in his work responsibilities and I
just really tried I've tried to bring
that with me because you know it's
important for us to remember the joy in
what we do it's important to be
effective in our workplace but it's
important to cultivate the moments that
just bring us joy because that's how
we'll shine in our in our lives as
professionals you know so you an actor
whose philosophy is to work or to wait
are you more of a like I'm not going to
do anything until I find the right thing
or you're just like I should be working
in a little bit of a workaholic but but
I can't but I need to I feel like I like
to take my time
I want to be able to select what I
should do I like to explore try to
explore different things different types
of of experiences but movies select you
and by that I mean the director and a
script they are the ones that are going
to throw the party and you want to be
you want to go to the best party you
know we use the metaphor of a party for
a movie so a good director and a
interesting story will always you know
dominate the choices that I make or
control the choices that I make because
if right now is a great director with an
interesting script comes to me and wants
me to do a character that might not be a
huge stretch but to be involved with a
what a team movies are not made alone
team is teamwork
that always will be like a exciting and
I might take the first place a good team
might take the first place but I like to
take my time but but I like to work too
so you know just a good balance you know
just keep a good balance
I don't think waiting to sometimes just
good to wait because you get exhausted
after doing movies you know you're kind
of like you know I give it give it a lot
of energy so I'm kind of like exhausted
but but you know a balance you know
might wait for a little bit and then do
one to two movies almost back-to-back
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion
and not one drop of myself work depends
on your it's something Sammy
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details